for their new single ichlauf fahrenheit
enlisted the help of german soul singer
cassandra steen
it's always very relaxing and inspiring
to work with cassandra
she'll sing lyrics or melodies you think
up and you know straight away if it was
a good idea or not
music producers eric mahol and andreas
yun formed fahrenheit two years ago
they find much of their inspiration in
nature and mix natural sounds with
electro they call their style nature pop
we're from berlin
and we don't have that much time to
relax
berlin is a cool city very creative you
know
it's great for making music but it can
also be very stressful and loud
so sometimes we have to switch off wind
down relax and the best way to do this
is with music
their debut album book of nature made it
to number 13 in the german charts last
year it featured the 2013 eurovision
song contest winner emily deforest from
denmark
one idea of course was the concept of
freedom
but not just the idea of being
completely free amid these vast
landscapes
it was also important for us to have
total musical freedom on this album
and that included being able to work
with different singers
voices that
such as the voice of singer-songwriter
amanda perez also from denmark
even though they like experimenting with
new age music and natural sounds
fahrenheit see themselves as pop artists
on their new album they cover depeche
modes enjoy the silence from 1990.
is
it also features amanda pedersen and is
a good example of fahrenheit's nature
pop
so how did they come up with their album
title home under the sky
when we were writing we noticed that
there was a theme running through the
whole album and that was home
we weren't thinking of a concrete place
but an inner feeling of home that can be
easily projected onto nature so we did
that in our songs too
it's here
fahrenheit always go one step further
traveling through the world of nature
sound and music